you see it on the masks they say the
Surgeon General the United States said
do not buy masks there they will harm
people if you buy the masks don't buy
masks then later you have to buy the
masks the disease will be spread on
surfaces the disease won't be spread on
surfaces the disease will be spread by
asymptomatic people the disease won't be
spread by asymptomatic people right the
list goes on and on and actually it gets
to a distinction you talk about a lot
the distinction between say progressives
or leftists and classical liberals right
well what the progressive project has
been telling us for a hundred years now
is forget about politics
forget about debate and persuading your
fellow citizens and engaging in
questions and making ethical choices
just pick some experts in lab coats they
are going to find the indisputable
answer they're gonna tell you all how to
live your lives and even if they
contradict themselves the next day we
just have to do what they say and I
think what we're beginning to learn now
is no we actually have a right to speak
about this - we're not just gonna
blindly follow you this is the Rubin
report and I'm Dave Rubin don't forget
to subscribe to that YouTube channel
we've got over there and click the
notification bell and joining me today
is the host of the Michael Noel's show
on The Daily wire and a best-selling
author Michael Knowles
welcome to the Rubin report Dave thank
you for having me
how is we not done this before something
doesn't seem right here like the
universe is sort of lining up right now
but how did this not oh I I like that it
took a pandemic for us to really do and
I don't
are we allowed to shake hands I don't
care can we I'm gonna shake your hand on
camera because you know this yeah I
think what the rest of the world doesn't
know this on Super Tuesday which was
what was that February was that March
it's like March 2nd it was a while ago
that was like right at the beginning of
Corona yeah Super Tuesday I'm with you
guys at the Daily wire just as Coronas
bubbling up you are the last hand that I
shook as I was walking out of there I
shake Shapiro's hand I shake Levens hand
whoever else in the crew and then I walk
out of there you're the last one that I
shake and then we went into lockdown the
next
so short of David I have not touched
another item the last one and yeah
according to the latest medical science
yeah if you ever get Corona it's my
fault
well the best part the best part of that
is that then it turned out that I guess
a few days before you were at where were
you use at CPAC you were at CPAC and it
turned out somebody at CPAC shook
somebody's hand about and I'm like man
I'm gonna get coronavirus now because
Noel's was that CPAC that's right he
shook my hand but yet we're both here
and we're both healthy we both survived
it is so funny cuz right after that the
reason that became a big story at CPAC
is I was there with senator Cruz and we
were doing this this live show yeah
we're in the green room and there were
there were a lot of important people in
the administration there was like
Kellyanne Conway it was Rhonda McDaniel
as the head of the GOP all these in this
very small room and one guy tested
positive for coronavirus so all of a
sudden you have all these people locking
down quarantine for weeks and weeks and
I thought I've just ruined the Reuben
report because I'm the last guy that he
touched but not only the Reuben report
if any of this had had a veracity that
they told us it was gonna have you would
have taken out the daily why are you
taking out half of Los Angeles and yet
we're all here well because we found the
cure you know we found the cure to
coronavirus which it turns out is
nationwide race riots race yes it's
right I thought it might be
hydroxychloroquine I thought it could be
they maybe get a vaccine note turns out
race riots that's the cure to the virus
although you're being slightly sarcastic
there you know we've had public
officials that have said that that has
literally said if we get the second wave
of Crona it will not be because of the
disease itself it will be because of
racism this is what one of the health
commissioner's of New York City said not
not just one it was this this letter
that came out a couple weeks ago I think
it was about 1200 over 1200 public
health officials who said there are
there are riots and it's a riot is that
there were protests going on with
peaceful very peaceful social justice
protests against racism those should be
encouraged from a public health
perspective but the protests that went
on a few weeks before against the
lockdowns
those must be discouraged because they
are mostly white and
I don't even know that's true yeah and
this was the kicker they said from our
perspective as scientists we know that
white supremacy which is totally a real
thing white supremacy is a public health
threat that exacerbates coronavirus this
was a shock to me I didn't we don't know
that much about the virus but we do know
that how do you feel being a pundit in
the stupidest time I've been thinking a
lot about this I think this is the best
time to be a pundit to be in politics
because we've been living in this
fiction for for an actually a number of
years now yeah which is that there is
science right and science with a capital
S trademark over the e is you can't
argue with science science tells you
what to do we bow down and pay obeisance
to the god of science and what we're
finding out is a lot of this science is
not so certain it's actually a little
bit more political than all that I mean
obviously in coronavirus they've
basically admitted are you telling me
that the whe oh the World Health
Organization could potentially
occasionally possibly be wrong about
things I would never want to contradict
the Chinese Communist Party we are on
YouTube I don't I don't I don't exactly
but this is the issue but II but that
sort of thing where it's like I mean
because we're so in the same world here
yeah that we have to believe these
people the second they say something
even though two weeks later they say the
complete reverse right related to masks
or whatever it is and then we are doing
this on YouTube and I'm sure they're
gonna suppress the views on this but the
simple truth is YouTube said you can't
contradict the w-h-o which contradicts
itself all the time right I mean what
the hell are we doing here you see it on
the masks they say the Surgeon General
United States said do not buy masks
there they will harm people if you buy
the masks don't buy masks then later you
have to buy the masks the disease will
be spread on surfaces the disease won't
be spread on surfaces the disease will
be spread by asymptomatic people the
disease won't be spread by asymptomatic
people right the list goes on and on and
actually it gets to a distinction you
talk about a lot the distinction between
say progressives or leftists and
classical liberals right well what the
progressive project has been telling us
for a hundred years now is forget about
politics
forget about debate and persuading your
fellow citizens and engaging in
questions and making it
Nicoll choices just pick some experts in
lab coats they are going to find the
indisputable answer they're gonna tell
you all how to live your lives and even
if they contradict themselves the next
day we just have to do what they say and
I think what we're beginning to learn
now is no we actually have a right to
speak about this - we're not just gonna
blindly follow you what do you think
this psychological underpinning of that
is with progressives because I get it
I've thought a lot about this I wrote
about this like what do you think it is
about the progressive mind that they
pretend they're anti-authoritarian all
the time and yet they love authoritarian
voices actually all their policies are
authoritarian all the every time there's
a study that proves what they want then
that's the right study and everybody
else is the racist study or something
like that but do you think there is like
a psychological reason to it I do I
think it actually it's it's a
philosophical and a psychological reason
and it goes back to Karl Marx and it
actually goes back to this idea of
science so if you go all the way back to
the word science science just refers to
knowledge it comes from the Latin word
for knowing things right and yet now the
word science has been minimized it's
been truncated into this little tiny
aspect of material inquiry and empirical
inquiry right so everything else that we
had we have to say that knowledge is
kicked out of that and what Mark said
was he discovered a science of history
mm-hmm and this is what progressives say
it's right there in the word progressive
is we're progressing towards something
it's inevitable Barack Obama used to
always quote Martin Luther King jr. who
would always say the arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice Payton basically meaning we're
inevitably hurtling toward this
progressive utopia and you you can stand
in the way for a little bit but you're
not really gonna stop it and so then
don't forget history will judge you and
hiss you'll be on the wrong side of
history right all of this language
basically turns politics into a science
and the reason it does that is so that
you can't disagree with it and that's
the science is always always right you
could never disagree with it and what
we're learning now is that was just an
excuse that was a facade to cover up
their political choices and so I think
the authoritarian impulse their comes
because they know that we're going to
paradise they see
utopia right ahead of us and so if you
stand in the way of utopia you can only
be one of two things really evil or
extremely stupid and either way we
shouldn't be listening to you and the
funny thing about this is they think the
word utopia means the best place but it
doesn't mean that the word actually
means no place it doesn't exist and I
think a lot of people are waking up to
that well there's a semi-autonomous Zone
in Seattle right thank you is there
utopia or whatever the hell is going on
there how old are you I don't I'm your
lady never tells but okay you're you're
a young fella yeah out there in the
political world and I always find it
interesting when when I meet younger
conservatives so especially now at
college when I meet younger
conservatives because I think yeah
although I do think this is changing now
for at least a decade really more than a
decade probably a couple decades to be a
young conservative was like you're just
sort of this dorky stuffy whatever
you're a nerd you you you know you care
about numbers you don't know anything
about culture you're not funny you don't
like comedy or any of these things were
you always a conservative and how do you
see that sort of changing right now
because I really see it changing I see
it I mean I think we're we're in the
midst of it changing pretty radically I
basically came out of the womb smoking
cigars but parted hair you're wearing
penny loafers if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell